okay
great
all right thanks very much can can
everyone hear the sound is working it's
all all good all right
excellent and i think i escape out of
this and i open my slides
all right
i'm too used to
teaching in lecture halls like this with
the mask on so
it comes naturally at this point
all right
so
open that
all right
okay well yeah thanks very much for the
invitation to
take take part in this event it was
really
uh a pleasure to be able to come here
and uh uh express my own appreciation
for
the incredible leadership role that the
science institute has played in the
theoretical computer science community
and the computing community more broadly
over these past 10 10 years
um and this is you know it was a chance
to kind of reflect on on these past 10
years overall you know my own connection
to simon's institute and also berkeley
uh more generally and really to reflect
on how 10 10 years really is a long time
in
a field especially a field that's
changing as actively as
computing right 10 years is a long time
from the perspective of
entire new communities that form
you know changes in one's own
research and even which will sort of be
some of the theme of my talk
changes in in the way you know you know
that i think back on uh topics that i
uh like very much and think about them
in new ways right so changes in the
in the field it obviously goes without
saying there's been this
enormous explosion of interest in what
you might call the societal implications
of computing right the past 10 years has
seen
computing which had already become this
unbelievably powerful force in the
online world really sort of step out
from the online world into areas like
employment education
uh the legal system the political
process and as we think about that we
think about the impact that's the design
choices that we make in purely technical
systems have on those societal
institutions and active research areas
have grown up we see you know
conferences that
um you know
really had you know a lot of uh impact
from you know
a lot of sort of inspiring generative uh
you know sort of roles played by people
with you know either in the theory
community with training in the theory
community uh many of these have both a
uh berkeley and a cornell connection as
many of you know and all of this really
is just really powerful to have new
areas that have emerged think about
these societal implications
and
my own work has certainly been informed
by these kinds of themes over these past
uh
10 10 years and i mean one of the other
of course amazing things uh that you
know those of you and
you know all of us in academia
appreciate is the way in which 10 years
is long enough that you know people that
you did not know 10 years ago become
very close colleagues of yours and so
you know as we've thought about these
these these issues right the way the way
in which computing uh plays a role both
in you know its societal impact and also
in the the potential for change um for
example in this paper in fact from a
couple years ago with a number of uh
colleagues some of whom are now your
colleagues here at berkeley as well
we've been thinking about sort of the
different roles computing plays here
right and a lot of these are really
recognizable for you know when we think
about you know the role that theory
plays as a unifying force in in these
kinds of areas right computing as a
diagnostic as a formalizer of what's
happening society as a rebuttal to
potentially
superficially conceived
solutions that on deeper inspection
might not actually work um computing as
synepticy right a word from
literary analysis in which the part
stands in for the whole and this is sort
of i think an important you know thing
that has been been coming up in
increasingly right synapticky when we
say the white house but we mean the
executive branch of the us government we
say the market but we mean you know not
the marketplace but the entire economy
um similarly computing in many of the
debates that we see playing out is often
a stand-in right that social media
becomes a stand-in for the entire media
and public in the uh information
ecosystem you know where new
developments in computer security become
really synechy for broader conceptions
in securing or broadly and maybe this is
part of how
theory plays some of its really pivotal
role here
which is that
it allows us to generalize ideas from
computing to these issues much more
broadly right to really take in that
picture much much more broadly and
that's really part of the power of
of theoretical approaches to be able to
to be able to do that
and finally not just these new
directions but
thinking about the societal impacts of
computing really also has caused me to
go back and think about uh you know
topics that i hold you know very
dear to my heart things like social
media right social media um and so
when i first spoke here at the simons
institute shortly after you know at the
kickoff conference shortly after it was
founded i put up pictures like like like
this which were quite recent at the time
you know arguing that something dramatic
had been changing in the world that
people were moving online that we were
seeing implications for your everyday
life as in this person's facebook member
neighborhood for political mobilization
as in the spread of this chain letter
across the internet
and of course the past decade um social
media has been you know a crucial issue
for everyday life for civic discourse
and the political process um and it
surely will be in the coming decade as
well now what's interesting of course is
that um
social media in a way
media has always been social right
there's something funny about calling
internet platforms social media because
if you go back to some of the founding
texts of the theory of mass
communication things by people like ella
who cats and paul lazersfeld um
they were talking about this as well in
the 1950s right so in 2004 at a workshop
i had the good fortune to meet the first
author of of this 1955 work elohim cats
and had a fascinating conversation about
how you know both he and i 50 years
separated we're interested in the
disruptive effects of technological
change on the political process right
for him it was things that we now think
of as sort of you know quaint like the
radio and tv uh and for me it was
blogging and social media but they were
arguing even then that you know in the
end these technologies were not really
what was affecting people's opinions in
this case for voting right rather when
they asked people what had consumed
their opinion it was other people
so
if media was always social yet this
feels new what's new and the real point
is that modern social media is
algorithmic media right that now what
you're seeing is computationally
mediated it's finally targeted often to
you specifically and it's being
optimized right by you know the very
kinds of algorithms that that we all
talk about every day and those are some
of the crucial feedback loops to
model now
because
media is social and because algorithms
can optimize this you know we ultimately
can manage actually quite a bit of
complexity in what we find in in the in
in the online world right so um
i try to sort of keep track of you know
when i
notice things on this and particularly
sort of notice the way you know sort of
my own reading or i'm sure all of your
own reading can sort of effortlessly map
out things that are really quite
complicated right so
for example um halfway between back then
when i gave those talks and now
spring of 2016 uh
the democratic presidential primary
um hillary clinton bernie sanders
rolling stone decided to endorse hillary
clinton for the democratic nomination in
2016.
and uh this blog that i've never seen
before since it's apparently called the
peoplesview.net um decided to talk about
a brilliant response from a millennial
to matt tybee's displeasure over this
endorsement that rolling stone had of of
hillary clinton
and i screenshot this at the time uh as
i think about social media because
there's something unbelievably
complicated about this sentence right
your brain processes it you know you it
doesn't at first seem like a
particularly strange sentence but it's
not a sense about hillary clinton nor is
it even
a sentence about rolling stones
endorsement hillary clinton or rather
matt tybee a former you know a sometime
writer for rolling stone was apparently
displeased of this but it's not about
his reaction either it's really about
the millennial who had the brilliant
response to it but you're not hearing
from the millennial you're really
healing from the peoplesview.net so
there's a cast of at least five
characters in this story
um right the media is social right the
story is about the connectivity and what
everybody thought of what everybody else
was saying
i should just of course add that you're
not actually reading the people's view
not now you're listening to me give a
talk about this so we can add some even
some more characters to this story so
right so media has always been social
but it is
algorithms heightened the complexity of
it right it allows us to assemble these
kind of complex structures and it's
being assembled by platform algorithms
that are effectively trying to give us
what we want
so now let's get to the next part of the
question which is why don't we usually
feel like we're getting what we want
right if you were to you know go online
and read the news media read what your
friends have to say about social media
the overriding sentiment would not be
one of customer satisfaction right it
would not be a sense that this is really
the experience i wanted to have why is
that right and is there something that
we can say about that and i think that's
been certainly one of the sort of
changes in you know in my own way i've
been trying to approach these questions
that 10 years ago the frame for for
example the talk i gave at the opening
conferences was one of
of optimism right i think i'm you know
potentially optimistic by nature perhaps
and the idea that we were connecting
people feels like you know this this is
this is a good thing and the idea that
algorithms are going to help us find
what we want you know we hope this is
going to be a good thing right why do we
feel this is not exactly entirely what's
happening so one issue is about conflict
right one point is that
the technologies as they've been set up
have been sort of
leading to a lot of conflict that arises
out of that connectivity
this is actually not going to be the
part that i'm going to focus on but i'll
mention that there's been a lot of
interesting work a lot of which raises
interesting
uh
mathematical problems in right in the
network dynamics of this and the
probabilistic dynamics of how things
like political polarization arise uh how
misinformation spreads how we can detect
it in beyond polarization radicalization
pathways whereby increased media
consumption some have argued and others
have uh
debated empirically
you know might lead people to more
extreme opinions than they had initially
the idea that they're actually media
should be yet another domain where we
actually take seriously the idea of the
adversary right a favorite topic in
theoretical computer science right that
right social media which is already
media also can become adversarial media
in which adversaries may attempt to
actually sow discord among the
participants purely for the sake of
discord uh and there's some work that uh
jason gaitandi avatars and i've been
thinking about recently on those kinds
of questions um the part i wanted to
talk about uh mainly though here
is uh some
new work that uh central lily nathan
who'll be a speaker here on friday and
manish raghavan uh a berkeley alum and
my former phd students will be starting
at mit this fall
the three of us have been thinking about
a different kind of conflict
one that's also recognizable but has not
somehow shown up nearly as much in the
kinds of models that have been built to
date and that's not about the conflict
between distinct people but about the
conflict social media creates within
each of us
right the conflict that's happening
within yourself as you consume social
media and
the
the more we looked at all of these
issues we began to feel like these
issues we can't fully understand without
understanding the internal issues the
internal conflicts that's that combat
now you know it's natural to ask like
so what what do we mean internal
conflict what is this internal conflict
so
let me show you some more uh
recent headlines right so the fact that
we have to invent a term called doom
scrolling right the fact that you have a
hard time stopping yourself late at
night from scrolling through public
health experts on twitter telling us
that certain you know case counts are
going quote nearly vertical and that
we're all in big trouble uh and yet you
know this simply heightens your stress
suggests that there's part of you that
wants to stop reading and part of you
that keeps reading
right the fact that people post on
reddit questions like how do i spend
less time on youtube
in some sense the answer feels obvious
perhaps you should stop going to
youtube.com
right and the fact there's apparently a
profession called professional internet
quitter
uh means people feel like they need help
in this domain right there's again this
complicated
right there's two parts of you here
right there's there's facebook there's
some party that wants to use facebook
and somebody who wants to override the
party that wants to use facebook
and apparently when you seek help on
this that person you're seeking help
from is effectively helping one side of
you in their struggle against the other
side of you
and so
sandal and venetian i started from here
and actually from some extremely useful
conversations which we had with teams at
some of these large internet platforms
um who
very much obviously to say the least are
aware and uh wrestling with these issues
and to think about could we you know
again
one of the things we might hope to do is
provide some kind of a sort of
theoretical vocabulary for thinking
about what's going on
so if we want to provide some kind of
theoretical vocabulary it helps to start
with some kind of a well-grounded
behavioral theory of what's happening
right this is not
new
and one advantage of working with
sandal on these projects is sendal
brings several decades of experience
working on exactly the kinds of
behavioral biases behavioral conflicts
in other domains that we sort of see
playing out in in this media environment
so let's go back to the behavioral
science and the behavioral economics of
self-control
right the question of why are we not
able to exert self-control when we
we
we go online and in the language of
behavioral science a lot of this is
about the distinction between
want and should right there's some
activities that are want activities and
some activities that are [ __ ] activities
right and uh you know a simple picture
tends to sort of drive this home
there are things we want and actually
the sort of assortment of food uh
outside is a kind of real life worked
example of this uh you can go check it
out later right so
and
the food literature is actually a lot of
where you know some of this early thing
comes from but it's also true in media
right people studying media consumption
have also thought about the distinction
between want and should right your
flight is
landing in three hours you're looking
for movies on the airlines entertainment
system you could watch the
fascinating documentary about a font
helvetica um or you could watch an
avengers movie
i actually recommend the font movie it
was it was quite good um the font movie
as you can see actually says at the
bottom if you can see this on the screen
start watching with your public library
card or university login because they're
pretty sure that the only people
watching this either have a public
library card or university login
and it's the same potato chips versus
salad right
part of you wants one part of you wants
the other
now the concern here
i should say before we get to the
concern um this is not it's not just
anecdotal examples right it's in the
nature of behavioral science to take
anecdotal examples from everyday life
and do empirical studies and so actually
this uh
team of behavioral scientists who were
uh
um
students and postdocs and faculty at
harvard at the time um looked at both
the food domain and the
media domain milkman rogers and bazerman
and found these distinctions actually
show up in you know sort of just found
data right so you look at online grocery
orders and orders placed further in the
future tend to contain more should items
right more vegetables more healthy food
nearer more want items and similarly
when netflix moved from being right
those of you
old enough to remember netflix was a
mail-order dvd company you put in your
request and dvds would arrive in the
mail and so the world actually
experienced a massive behavioral science
experiment when they switched to
streaming because netflix had always
been about what does what do i think
myself three days from now will want to
see possibly a movie about the font
helvetica
versus what
do i want to see like literally right
now at the press of a button
and when that change happened you could
actually see
the shift in what movies were actually
selected and of course there was some
interesting timing there because for
those of you who again roughly 10 years
ago remember the netflix prize
competition netflix offers one million
dollars to anyone who can improve their
recommendations that was on data
from the mail order era
but the solution arrived roughly as they
were pivoting to the streaming era and
so there was a kind of massive shift in
actually what the data was potentially
now going to be telling us
okay so obviously this is you know the
self-control issues are in turn grounded
on you know issues and time and
consistency right there are multiple
time scales happening here
okay
the reason to be concerned of course is
that
um
we have these problems when we select
and that selection and that shows up in
our the data on how we select
and platforms are using that data to try
to figure out what we want right that's
the crux of it the basic a basic
question maybe the basic question
platforms must answer is what do users
want right what does this user want what
does any of us want and
it's sort of you know in 10 years ago i
actually um
was sort of you know a sort of mantra
that i was very happy to say in talks
was the amazing thing about the online
world is we have unbelievably
fine-grained data right we have this
click-through data that shows in real
time what everybody quote wants
and and that is fundamental to how these
platforms these platforms would not work
without that right the principle of
revealed preference people choose what
they want so choice reveals preference
right we can't do away with that
but in a sense what we're here to argue
is that that question
is much more complicated than it seems
because the question of what you want is
much more complicated than it seems
right and that really
we should model that selection as
happening through a conflict between
multiple sets of preferences right the
reason this seems so hard is that you do
not have one set of preferences you have
multiple sets of references and
different of them are in control at
different times and what you're watching
in that data which was so fine green and
so high resolution is this strange
interleaving of the choices you make as
different parts of you are in control
right and that if we sort of just
naively take that as the data we're
going to have a very hard time
decrypting what's going on where right
it's again sort of like you know like
food and i think we sort of see the food
analogy at this point you know
you're at a party and you stand next to
the bowl of chips and you sort of
mindlessly finish it and the host shows
up and part of you would like them to
refill the bowl um part of you hopes
they take the bowl back to the kitchen
and don't bring it out again and the
point is
that you know when you sort of naively
think about platform algorithms and i
should stress you know the fascinating
conversations we've had with people at
these platforms
it's they're certainly
anything but naively and and they're
thinking about this but when you just
sort of approach this as a first pass
a simple recommendation algorithm is
going to refill the bowl of chips every
time i mean it knows what you want it
just saw you finish a whole bowl of
chips right and so that's essentially
the problem that you're fighting against
right that you see people clicking on
things
what is the signal that might tell you
maybe this is actually where they want
to stop even though they're still
clicking
okay so
so that's that's the issue now the point
is
that and
let's try to start building a model now
right like it'd be nice to actually have
a language for talking about this i've
given you some behavioral
science
concepts and some empirical studies but
let's actually try to build a model of
this conflict in the specific context of
social media
so and the point that we'll see is that
whether revealed preference leaves the
correct conclusion it's not that
revealed preference is right and it's
not that it's wrong it's that whether it
leaves the correct conclusion depends on
the nature of the content
okay and you know whether the content is
sort of salad-like or chips-like and so
that's what we would really like to talk
about when does real preference work
when does it not how do we recognize the
distinction between these two things and
to appreciate that at some point
quantity becomes quality the problem
becomes qualitatively differently when
you imagine that the social media
platform is really like the billion
product grocery store where every time
you touch the shelf it's reconfiguring
uh and meanwhile in the back
the food is being bio-engineered to
optimize for your particular taste right
so the speed at which things are
changing is just very different from the
domains in which behavioral sciences
approach this right it's very different
from the speed at which news editors
decide what tomorrow's front page will
say or grocery stores decide what to
stock this is happening literally as
you're scrolling through your timeline
lower down the timeline is actually
reconfiguring based on what you're
pausing to look at okay that's what we
have to have to deal with okay so
for a model
start with a simple model um and i for
the sake of being able to sort of digest
all this in real time i'll sort of keep
all the kind of knobs and dials turned
down to sort of as simple as possible in
the work we've been doing we're looking
at a number of other generalizations
let's actually start with a linear
content feed right so you're scrolling
through a news feed a timeline
you're auto playing videos one after
another
and so you know just ty items t equals
zero one two so forth your main decision
is do you continue or do you stop
okay and then later on we can try to add
you know branching which choice do you
pick and so forth because a lot of the
ideas are going to just carry over to
that
and again you have conflict between your
preferences and so to again borrow some
language from behavioral science let's
say these are these two sets of
preferences system one and system two
now system one system two actually get
used in a lot of parts of behavioral
science um and we're gonna sort of only
use sort of pieces of it but system one
is the impulsive
uh preference system it acts faster
right so it it moves first if if it's
engaged it just acts before planning
system two is the slower
retrospective more planning uh aspect of
the preferences and it's going to
actually make a plan do i want to be
here am i still getting value out of
this it's able to plan do i want to go
on this platform at all
okay and system one just impulsively
grabs the next chip
okay so how should we model system one
now system one has preferences it just
acts on them very quickly so item t
let's imagine produces some utility u
sub t for system one drawn from some
distribution u
and
ut
system one is not really adding up
utility every time it's just saying is
this in my interest or not so the key
parameter is simply p the probability
that ut is positive okay ut gradient
zero is probably p and if so system one
continues on to item t plus one
if u t is less or equal to zero system
one is not interested in what it's doing
right now it temporarily powers down
and hands over control to the slower
moving system two which wakes up and
gets to actually decide whether it wants
to be here or whether it would like to
leave right these are these sort of
moments when you're able to reflect and
say
maybe i should actually stop eating
chips or stop scrolling through public
health experts telling us all how doomed
we are okay so
what does system two do
so system two uses long range planning
but only when it's in control
so it too has uh preferences and you can
start imagining right so it has
preference vt for item t from some
distribution v you can start imagining
that presumably the correlation between
uh this distribution u and distribution
v is going to be important right um
okay so
let's say the average utility that
system two gets is v bar from
you know because it doesn't know what's
coming but it in expectation you sort of
know the quality of tweets you're going
to see you sort of know the quality of
videos you're going to see
but it also has an outside option right
has some reason it wants to leave this
outside option w for leaving the site so
it's net utility from item t is vt minus
w
uh it doesn't know the exact utility of
future items but knows that for the next
item it's expected utility is v bar
minus w
okay
okay we need one more thing which is
if v bar is bigger than w
why does system two ever want to leave i
mean every time it's in control it sees
that the expected future utility is
positive
and the reason is satiation right we
don't right so this is a hedonic
activity consuming media eating dessert
snacks whatever and so we're eventually
going to reach diminishing returns from
this hedonic activity and so we're going
to imagine that system 2 is receiving
these diminishing returns there are
various ways to do this and again for
this talk to keep everything sort of
that we can all sort of do the math in
our heads as we're watching i'm going to
take the simplest formulation
that we use
we imagine that system two goes through
a kind of on off satiation transition so
at every step with probably q it decides
it is now satisfied and it is done it
would now it would now prefer to leave
okay
so
and it can plan for this it knows that t
steps from now the chance that it is
going to actually want to see this imt
section now is q to the t right it has
to survive t coin flips going to the
future
okay and that's how system two thinks
about things
so the content has three parameters that
matter there's the value of the content
per item
right and that's this v bar minus w
value minus option there is the
satiation parameter right the rate at
which you sort of saturate on the
content which we'll call you know the
span that controls the expected time
span the system two wants to be there
that's probably cue that system two
remains interested
and then again i'll take this term from
uh behavioral science moorishness right
certain activities are moorish in that
system one just keeps wanting more of
them and that's the probability p that
system one is in control when consuming
a piece of content
okay so that's how this works a given
piece of content if system one is
engaged it gets to control it's in
control and it moves on
if it's not engaged system two wakes up
and can actually do some calculation and
decide is my future expected value take
into account the value the outside
option and the upcoming satiation
and
the chance that i'm not gonna be in
control for a while
all of that
um
does that justify staying on the
platform
so actually with that in mind we can
actually just work out
what should system two's calculation be
right it is all of those things
so
system two can think okay here's what my
session
on the platform is going to look like
well it's gonna go in two phases first
before i satiate and second after i say
sheet in phase one system two wants to
continue while it's waking up and again
we because we're choosing the simple
model that we can work out you know just
here on the slides this is a memoryless
process and so every time it wakes up
it's doing the same calculation from any
point where it wakes up the expected
number of steps left
while it still wants to be there is one
over one minus cube
right and if we had something that
wasn't memoryless we'd have to do a more
elaborate calculation
and the expected utility for this part
is this you know utility per time divide
you know times one over one minus q okay
that's the part it gets
then it satiates does it get to leave
well not immediately because system one
might be in control right there's now
this sort of coda this epilogue to the
whole thing where system one is in
control and it's impulsively continuing
even though system two is no longer
deriving value right and in that sense
it's actually
gaining utility of minus w every step
because there's this opportunity cost
from being trapped on the platform here
right and
how long is this going to go on well it
could last zero steps so there's a
factor of p but it's p over one minus p
right the one over minus p times chance
p that that's immediate
okay so you could think of right system
one and system two go to a party
together and system two is enjoying it
for a while but at some point system two
wants to leave but do they get to leave
no because they have to extract system
one from the party and system was
impossibly having a whole bunch more
conversations uh while system two would
really rather leave right and that is
the experience of you a single person on
social media as these two sets of
preferences are fighting for control
okay
so
system two's utility is this random
variable uh right this
random variable s um which is
either this thing right the value from
phase one i guess i can if i point with
this thing you can see it right yeah
there you go um
you know minus uh the value that loses
in phase two the max of that in zero
because the point is
system two in our model and again
actually this is a fascinating point to
consider
who controls the decision to go to the
platform right and i'll actually come
back to this point because
there are design choices that actually
affect this but let's imagine you know
the platform requires you actually like
you know
getting your phone opening it whatever
so
that's a planning activity that's not
impulsive activity system two
let's imagine this model is in control
but let's go back and revisit that later
so it only does that if expectation of s
is not negative
okay
when the user chooses to visit the
platform there's a second metric that's
very interesting which is the length of
the session the like this session is
just the length of the first phase one
of one minus q plus p over one minus p
the length of the second phase
okay
now the length of the session is not
just sort of an incidental quantity here
it is a quantity that is sort of heavily
thought about
in platform context right it is the
user's level of engagement with the
platform right if you're looking at
metrics for the platform you might
discover that last you know last month
people spent you know 22 minutes uh per
session on watching videos on the
platform and this month they spend 24
minutes right engagement has gone up
okay and that's the expectation of t
and then there's this invisible thing
utility right where the user's happy
because they spend 24 minutes instead of
22 minutes that's sort of the mystery
and that's right and that lets us sort
of write down this tension right that we
have these two quantities
and if we think about session length t
is measuring engagement
what is the relation to utility
expectation of s
and
even a model this simple
sort of shows us how these things are
partly aligned
and partly misaligned right they each
have a first term that has one one over
one minus q a factor one over a nice
cube right so increasing the span of the
content
lengthens sessions and makes people
happier right and that's in a sense
somehow the basic argument for
engagement optimization right it's from
the idea that if i can have things that
where the diminishing returns operate
slower then people are just getting more
value
but the second term causes t to go up
and has to go down
right
and so
the problem is if i'm just i i can't
know what's in your mind we'll come back
to that point too right maybe i can ask
you survey questions i can sort of ask
you how satisfied are you today on the
platform but if i'm just looking at
click data
then if i see long engagement it could
come because of the first term that's a
good thing it could come from the second
term and that's a bad thing
and more than that
if
p gets too high the user might just one
day stop showing up at all right because
they're no longer getting value from the
platform
so
now we've sort of crossed over into this
last thing i wanted to uh discuss in the
talk briefly that
now i'm talking about platform
optimization right until this moment i
was talking about the user's experience
on the platform a model of your internal
conflict but as we think about it the
platform is choosing right it's
tailoring the content to you and it has
to decide where in the space do i want
to be and the space we've defined has
these three dimensions p the moorishness
the appeal system one q the span
uh the right the amount of time system
two wants to be there and v the v bar
the value right per unit item and so
the content lives in some feasible
region in the space
and implicitly the platform is moving
around in the space right parameterized
by some coordinates it has control over
proposing
distributions of content to you and then
seeing what happens and let's imagine
the platform can measure engagement but
can't directly measure utility
and so the question is if the platform
is optimized moving around on this
feasible region optimizing for
engagement what is the effect on utility
and the point is that
it's
not just the answer is good news or the
answer is bad news it depends on the
shape of this feasible region so let me
show you some examples of some feasible
regions to just show you and so this
will mainly be worked examples i'll
mention one result at the end then i'll
wrap up
sounds great
so
first example imagine there's some base
point you know on this manifold of
possible content p q naught v naught and
i have control of some parameter x right
i have this lever if i'm the platform i
can move the lever i'm not quite sure
what this lever does but i'm going to
try moving it and see what the reaction
from the users is but imagine what the
lever actually does is it increases q
and increases v well then obviously the
engagement goes up and the utility goes
up and this manifold is sort of the
canonical thought experiment why
engagement optimization is good but of
course i might have
when i grab the lever and move it a
different thing might be happening right
it might be that what the lever is doing
is increasing p
now something different will happen i
will see users spending
longer and longer on the platform right
so as i move this x value changing p
then we have this plot on the right the
orange curve is time on platform it just
goes up up up up but unbeknownst to me
the utility is going down down down and
down because it's getting longer just
because people are sort of finding
themselves unable to tear away and it
rises to this peak after which one day
the user stops showing up at all right
so what i've done is at the moment the
user seems most engaged in the platform
that's the moment they suddenly stop
showing up right
okay and so that's the situation that
you want to avoid and of course
things are always more complicated right
moorishness is never decoupled from
overall system two satisfaction right
things that appeal to system one
typically also appeal to system two and
so you can imagine we have even slightly
more complicated feasible regions where
the the lever i've grabbed is raising
the moorishness
but it's also raising the value per item
right you know like when i make the
chips slightly a bit more moorish you
know they also system two likes them
more also
and so there we actually end up with
some internal optimum and so part of
this content manifold
engagement is a great signal as i ride
up the engagement i'm surface i'm
actually making the user happier but i
still have to know where to stop because
as i keep going the engagement signal
won't tell me to stop engagement keeps
going up
as i burn away all the utility and one
day the user again stops showing up at
all
and
we can build lots of these things by
mixing right so by creating sort of
mixing weights among the content
and so
um again
this
sort of i'm carrying this out at the
level of worked examples um one general
thing that we can show is you know if we
want to characterize when is uh
a feasible region
when for a feasible region is engagement
a good signal for
utility
um or conversely when is it not right so
i have some feasible region i have the
expected utility and expected uh
engagement and then i have the
optimizers for both of these right a
point that optimizes utility a point
that optimizes engagement
and
one question is when does the engagement
optimizer produce strictly higher
engagement but strictly lower utility
than the utility optimizer and one thing
we can show is that they're actually um
when that happens right when these two
signals are actually not aligned one of
two things must hold one is that i do
have
greater moorishness at the engagement
optimizer right that i've i've over
optimized for engagement precisely by
raising moistness and there's actually a
second possibility that comes out of the
model and makes sense in retrospect
which is i can also create high
engagement with lower value
if the span of the content for system
two is longer but the value per time is
lower what does that correspond to that
actually corresponds to another thing
the platforms know about which is
if the quality of my search
results uh you know the quality of my
video search results product search
results google search results gets worse
you can get this paradoxical effect
where users of course spend longer on
the platform because it takes them
longer to find what they need right so
they're spending longer they're getting
less value they're still satisfied they
still keep coming back and you have to
recognize that right no one wants to
spend time searching and so that's
actually the second alternative and one
of these two things greater moorishness
or essentially lower quality per time is
sort of at the root of this all right i
will
wrap up with just some
final
reflections right our goal here was to
sort of start from the sense that
something isn't working with platform
optimization based on behavioral data
right we feel that we go online
you know you feel that and i feel that
behavioral science tells us that there's
a reason why we might feel that and to
really try to build that into a model
of how to recommend content on online
media that really takes into account
this internal conflict and what's been
interesting is how this model lets us
think about a lot of design choices i've
been talking a lot about how to
interpret the data we collect
um there are issues like the role of
surveys right how can i directly elicit
information about utility from you by
asking you questions right it doesn't
have to be necessarily invisible these
questions about like the number of
options to display right i've i've run
through this talk purely about a linear
feed you have to decide when to stop as
i present you with options right system
one now has more things to click on but
there's also greater you know you're now
maximizing over all those options for
value
there's this interesting fact about the
benefits of enforced breaks
right if i mix in
you know parts where there's like zero
value right i i say time to take a break
you know and we've seen in instagram
introduced this we've seen tik tok
introduced this in the last few months
the model actually tells us that could
actually cause users who have gone away
to come back
right because it's now saying i've
actually brought down the moorishness
because system two can be confident that
periodically system one is going to
power down due to the enforce break and
you can evaluate if you want to leave
right and so the fact that platforms are
like we're going to add 30 seconds of
boredom every half hour means that you
know this is actually something that can
be quite powerful and something that the
model is telling us about
finally the unexpected benefits of
embedding media in other content i think
there's a very interesting question
about back to who controls the decision
to go on
on the platform in the first place right
and you know obviously the more friction
there is right the more you have to like
open your laptop open the browser right
that's a expensive activity the more you
can just pick up your phone right the
more system one starts coming to play
and it lets you think about embedded
media also right it's entirely possible
to say things like i normally read the
washington post but not on sunday
mornings because they always embed clips
from last night's saturday night live
and now suddenly although i know to stay
away from youtube i'm suddenly watching
youtube in the middle of this washington
post article and system one takes over
right right so the whole idea of
embedding media in other media means
that you know you may have safeguarded
this thing away right system two is
staying away from this thing but
suddenly system one is there right you
see this in the food context right you
walking through the airport concourse
know not to stop and buy
the 1200 calorie cinnamon roll
at the kiosk but the cinnamon roll place
in the airport knows to pipe the smell
out onto the concourse which means as
you walk by system one is already eating
the cinnamon roll right you're already
engaged and so this this question like
who controls the decision to join
is also something that shows up
obviously very clearly in in this model
so what's been interesting is just to
try to create this vocabulary where we
can talk about these things that were
really sort of hard to talk about right
not just you know the conflict not just
at the sort of macro scale or the
visible scale but at this invisible
skill within each of us uh it's been
very interesting both sort of you know
trying to think about the options for
models and also talking with again teams
at a number of these platforms um and i
think it'll lead to a lot of
very interesting questions going forward
and i think you know questions very much
in the spirit of bringing together you
know many of these different areas many
different perspectives together with
theoretical computer science that i
think you know the simon's institute
really very much has represented for the
past 10 years thanks very much
um
thanks thanks john that was a great talk
um i had a question about the richness
of the of the model so you know you
might you might ask about models whether
they are rich enough to
to support various kinds of phase
transitions and so on yeah so one thing
that one might think about here in this
context is that there's a phenomenon
that that that might be very important
which is addiction yeah and there might
be incentives for
social media companies to
to actually engage that that side so do
these do the models that you are looking
at
actually display all these phases you
know you might say well these are the
phases we'd like to see in these models
and do do they actually display these
these phases yeah so that's a great
question right so yeah this question
about does it capture addiction so i
think you know in some sense as we yeah
so there is this interesting thing that
we're sort of trying to work on as you
think about pqv space right and i sort
of partition that um i'm you know i'm
able to think about sort of how these uh
those things i'm able to think about
sort of how you know
how the platform's decisions relate to
the user's utility um and of course i
should emphasize that you know platforms
ultimately are optimizing for long-term
value right that's even in their in
their self-interest and so something
which is going to sort of turn off users
in the short term is not going to be in
their interest but they they may not
realize that they're steering into that
i think it's part of the challenge the
other uh the other issue is yeah so
addiction i think
in the behavioral science literature
addiction has these two components right
one is the moorishness you just keep
doing it and and that's very much in the
model the second is the attenuation of
the stimulus right that when you come
back you need more to achieve the same
effect
um and that actually right so that says
that some of these parameters would be
dynamically changing in in you to
achieve you know the same enjoyment the
next time you have to spend
even longer right because addiction is
basically attenuating the signal that
part is not explicitly in the model
right now that's that's something we
very much think about trying to include
which would sort of round out the kind
of second half of the addiction picture
potentially
would you say that to a first order
approximation if a platform is
ad supported then it would try to
optimize for engagement and if it is say
subscription supported it would try to
optimize for utility
it's a great question i mean so i think
if your subscription's supported
certainly argument is utility i so i
would say the
i would say ad supported
creates a conflict for the platform
right so as in there's a discount factor
going on right obviously
if you want to maximize your revenue
today
i should keep using the platform
clicking on edits but no platform wants
to maximize its revenue today they want
to maximize some infinite discounted
revenue
over time and it's
it's it's it's very clear that you know
uh sort of causing users frustration now
is actually going to sort of hurt
retention in the in the long run so you
definitely see metrics i think that are
about playing out over a long time even
for ad support platforms and so now you
have these challenges right one is the
whole set of challenges here that
utility is partly in invisible like only
indirectly estimated from people
returning and so forth the other is the
longer time scale right if i show you
something and you click or don't i can
get like a huge number of reactions very
very quickly in real time
knowing whether a change is sort of
increasing or decreasing the number of
people who sort of come back on a daily
or you know weekly basis is going to be
a much slower time scale and so i think
there's also a fascinating questions
here about the the feedback signals
right so there's sort of a giant
reinforcement learning question here
going on the rate at which the feedback
is coming in can be at the level of
seconds for clicks and at the level of
weeks for sort of
daily return platforms unambiguously
would like to be optimizing for return
they want you to still be here in a year
and that's going to be very much against
sort of hitting you with annoying ads
but it's very hard to measure and
optimize for it
we're not all the same so it's like you
know there's some teachers which are
better for some students and there are
some different behavior modes i assume
that there's it's not every person is
different but there's some clusters yeah
so how's that going to the model yeah
that's right so the question is like
right differences in people so i mean so
one thing is types of people types of
people yeah so these parameters
you know p q v
those are specific to you right and so
an interesting thing that we also are
thinking about now is like this is
actually a story about one person and a
platform it was really about
heterogeneous population platform each
of whom has their own distribution of
pqv and so you know for me you know a
piece of content that's moorish but low
quality might for you actually not be
morish at all and be very high quality
right and so like some people genuinely
don't like documentaries about fonts and
some people do and so there's gonna be
like every item is going to be different
for every user and right they're going
to be types of users and so and so i
think one thing that we've been looking
at a little bit uh is
as the platform changes the content
you'll see people differentially leaving
right and so actually another way to try
eliciting some information about utility
is to watch the sort of differential
departure of people right people are
leaving the ones who are staying or
staying for longer that may tell us
something about that wedge based on
exactly the differences
fantastic let's thank him again and
thank you
and that is i'd like to thank our
incredibly tireless and thank and
excellent superb staff who put this
event together and maybe all the staff
that are here can you stand up and we
can give them a round of applause we'll
do it again but
thank you very much and uh